[Music]
four four
[Applause]
i wasn't ready to start uh but so i just
sang that song i'm trying to not sing
that song every
opening i like it i do too but i think
it's enough already it's time to update
the good for you song
and we're gonna do it at some point i've
asked dave grohl's daughter
violet to make it and she's
too successful to do it at the moment
but she will do it eventually
she's gonna help she's just even other
projects his daughter is more successful
than we are
they're giving it to an intern yeah so
uh we are working on that
um paris hilton is on the podcast today
this was not a prank she actually came
to my house it was
in person utterly terrible to the
unfinished home
it was utterly terrifying she basically
lured her into a haunted house
my house is under construction i was so
worried something was like fall on her
head and like ruined the most
uh profitable brand in america it was
like a haunted house too because we all
hid in mass and we scared her when she
walked by
so that was so weird we all there was
like a weird
vibe of terror when she was here she's
just but it wasn't
she just i loved it too she smells so
good
yeah she's like a human clown she hugged
me she hugged me she has the soft his
hair
she smells like you think she would
smell yeah she talks like this
okay she's gonna get a restraining order
let's take it easy but no it was just
weird it's like
like it's just you're it's just i've
seen her and hung out with her so many
times or there's something about having
her in your house where you're just like
yeah why did i let you come here right
like this is dangerous is this a simple
life are you gonna make fun of me
[Laughter]
she's like i'm rebooting the simple life
the first stop is your house she's like
a
studio i just was like
you realize how sort of dirty your house
is and
like when she's around you're just like
oh she's gonna like get a splinter with
one white glove on she's like
by the way you know no she didn't touch
anything
uh thank you i remember because none of
our bathrooms work only this one
bathroom
in this weird guest room works and has
no handle but by the way there's no
handle on it everyone gets locked in the
bathroom
um we i we i
wanted to drag grace into this and she
doesn't deserve it i set up the bathroom
with a bunch of products that
i like pretended to use i had like that
oh we thought
like like a lorac like skin primer like
i tried to like impress her with the
products in my bathroom
it was very yeah as if she was gonna
she's like none of these are my
fragrance so that's right
yeah she's like where's my skincare
seems like none of my products are here
so that's a little odd
by the way as if and then i put a bunch
of like unused like hair and makeup
stuff out as if she was gonna need
and as if she wasn't gonna be so beat
and hot perfect when she got here
yeah that's so funny i was like here's
some like uh uh
head and shoulders uh anti-frizz i was
like what is all this
it's a nightmare it's like walking into
a pharmacy isn't it just for kids
garnier champagne i was like no tears
prell like all my products were just
like so embarrassing and i went in there
like two days ago and was like oh my god
what is all this like she must have just
think i'm bad
and then you need to clean it all up
you're like i got it all back yeah
and re-gifted and put in someone's gift
bag i took a lot of it yeah i know
you're like thank god you didn't touch
it i can give it away
can we turn it no i wish he hadn't
touched it so i could put it on ebay and
retire
um so paris hilton is on the podcast uh
today it was
i i feel like we saw a different side of
her yeah
i asked the most random and appropriate
so the questions were
so random so dumb so good but i think
the
people always my deal with this podcast
is i want to ask people questions that
they don't ever get asked on other
shows and you did and i just wasn't
asking those yeah
for a good reason he's like you know i
have a job like there's like things you
could ask me
like i don't know you ever smelled
bleach before
what's that like i was asking very brave
because i was trying like
i just feel like she's been so cornered
as this sort of
slick statuesque enigma that's i just
wanted to ask her just like very
everyday normal questions yes and
yeah it was good yeah and she was just
sort of like i should probably
the fact that they're letting us air it
is shocking um uh
and the fact that it didn't ruin our
friendship is uh uh doubly shocking
a couple announcements before we get to
a paris hilton
paris whitney hilton paris and paris
paris and perry emily and perry that's
how it's supposed to be pronounced
correct which is so funny to me that
emily and paris
they thought it rhymed emily and perry
emily in paris it does matter but it's
only around if you're a psychopath where
they're just were they only making it
for french people
didn't they know that we're gonna make
emily in paris
texas yeah i think first of all i
thought this took place in texas
at the paris las vegas casino
[Laughter]
speaking of uh casinos uh the tour is
back on
the world is opening up we have booked
so many stand-up dates we're right now
just doing what is
possible which are smaller venues which
i find
very exciting that we i mean i don't
know we don't normally get to do
i do clubs when i'm building up a
special and you know as comedians it's
like
the idea is for your ego and impress
everyone you got to do theaters and you
got to do the biggest venues possible
but now because those venues aren't
quite open yet
they will be open in the fall we're
going to announce a ton of new dates
um but we're doing a lot of clubs that
are either half capacity now full
capacity
spokane washington um if you guys have
any good cocaine let us know
um because i need to be more manic um
so we've we added what do you think we
do here we added a ton of shows
but the ones that are not sold out are
april 15th the late show
friday april 16th at 4 00 p.m early
so for all you uh getting bused in from
rehab
that's your show um uh sunday april 18th
at 9
30. so when you stumble out of church
sober up
come to the show people leave church at
eight eight p.m very religious people
i you think they're into sleep away i i
meant leave church
in the aaa meeting that's held at a
church oh i was like
what's this church of spain
so here's the big thing the big thing is
we added a ton of dates for the fall
tour that are not necessarily on the
website
um and we're gonna need to name that
fall tour i love it so these club dates
are not part of the big fall tour yet
we're gonna be in san antonio tejas
we had to move it to the 30th and add
another show on the saturday and early
show
because i'm doing uh the liza koshy
television show
i got asked to do that too well yes i
think you might be on the same episode
as me
i play a narcissistic um
like bullshit wellness guru and uh
you've worked with your character you've
worked with exactly so it's a
documentary
you've worked with quite a bit of those
yes quite a few um i'm gonna do the liza
koshy tv show
um uh and so we just we just moved the
dates around so
some of you if you bought tickets on
thursday we're just gonna move those to
saturday and thank you for your patience
a bump during this time
um uh after that we are going to go to
houston texas
may 13th to 15th come on houston improv
i love that room and i've not done it in
so long it is such a blast that's at
full capacity so
let's let's all go um
may 7th and 8th brea california which is
like right outside
los angeles for los angeles people come
all new material
it'll be worth the drive listen to one
podcast and you're there
um dallas texas may 20th to 22nd
phoenix arizona may 29th to june
3rd also houston on may 13 through 15th
i said that
i thought well we jumped oh i jumped
around yeah
um and uh tempe arizona
so i'm gonna be in phoenix and tempe for
basically a week and a half i'm doing
cb live may 29th to june 3rd in phoenix
in phoenix then tempe improv june
4th through 6th that's my birthday
weekend that's why we booked this so
that i'd be out of town
uh she'll be there i'll be there
and uh baltimore maryland coming
june 10th through 12th get your blue
crabs ready
goobies
reno nevada this is a date from when
taylor tomlinside
taylor tomlinson and i were touring
together
and uh we had to reschedule it so many
times because of govind so now we're
like like in june 23rd we're just gonna
do
one date together which is just so weird
uh
and then september through december
we are doing a ton of new dates that are
not even up on the website
yet but i think they're going to happen
i think the fall is going to happen oh
yeah schools i think schools are going
to be back i don't think you can put the
genie back in the bottle at this point
even if things do get crazy
yeah right you can't the genie back to
you make three wishes anyways
um okay well now you're just semantic
yeah now this is a semantics thing i get
it you know more about genies than i do
um i want to confront youtube about
do you notice anything different about
me have you noticed anything different
about me in what way
where you didn't notice physically
personally yeah what do you mean
no you guys have noticed nothing
different about me
i'm now well you have yogurt pretzel
stains all over
me how dare you think it's just
a milky thing give me some credit that's
disgusting it's pretzels i mean
yogurt pretzels you're wearing one
earring that's all the time
that you know so what's different oh
your butt what about you what about your
booty
i bet what about it you don't notice a
bigger it's
voluptuous i'm wearing my padded
underwear
you put in those two tortillas and you
thought that did something
you put in those you stuffed those two
tortillas down your pants and you said
i'm onika watch excuse me start
apologizing to people for your body i'm
not shy
i'm just too embarrassed about excuse me
guys on my thigh that i got from
uh doing a weed edible uh too early in
the day uh which too early talk about at
some point three days off the wheat
edibles
guys uh never been uh more clear and not
stuttering as much
that is a paper thin butt pad and you
are walking around like you were on nika
mirage herself
you are apologizing excuse me you might
get this door guys i don't take up all
the room pardon me pardon me
pardon all this
my hips are coming through but here's
the thing my ass has gotten so flat
during quarantine
uh thank you to covid and edibles
um that it's gotten so flat that even
when i put on
un padded underwear that's supposed to
lift your butt no one notices that's how
flattered my butt is like
there's no padding in those there is
feel that there is
no whitney what you could have shut that
that t-shirt down there and done more
that is nothing okay well i didn't want
to go
too oh yeah i want it to look natural
yeah
you know so yeah i can't tell i wanted
to look natural did you guys notice it
my butt is like too hot and it looks
like i have two like mini vaginas on
each side no you already have a good
butt
and a great body i don't know what
you're talking about but i want a bigger
butt and
then you should get this i'm an idiot
and i spent a bunch of money on bigger
and those aren't those are out and butts
are in and we're going to start to go
fund me for you
i can't do the butt implants because you
have to lay on your stomach for three
months and i got fake
i can't let myself get at all yeah it's
always a down dog i really think that
through
it's always a what's this in yoga you
can lay on your side
cobra is that it you can lay on your
side
with a bunny i mean i'm not really
getting bottom plants but i i but you
could if you want them
if i want them i could totally i just
like you i can't sit for like three
months
no podcast it's two weeks
and we'll get standing desks we'll all
get button plants and we'll get standing
desks so we're all the same eyeliner
i don't want a button plant okay well
you know what emily everyone wants to
get one so
the jury has spoken it is so it is
so hot in here okay well you're not
wearing a butt implant right no
panties right now you know what i have
on you know you don't know what i'm
wearing
how swampy this palette it's like a
soaking wet they're like two
wet sponges it should absorb sweat that
should be nice
yeah what if there was padding in it but
those are just panties so
they were too absorbable uh like you
know that you should have put dish
sponges down
like you know the chicken cutlets that
we used to have before they were like
the
the mushy gelatinous ones the viscous
ones it's foam it's just
that foam that's what it is you know
what it is you know why you think those
are padding if i threw these away it
would kill a turtle in the ocean because
i can't get rid of it you know why you
think those but
those underwear you know why you think
that underwear is padded because you're
used to thongs
so you think that because it's full
coverage you have a thicker
there's just fabric touching your face
just that's what how about that i have
worn thongs for 25 years i don't worth
all you should thongs are the only ones
i i wear long johns and i said why if i
could i could you mean
you know you we need to move you to
songs because i can see that
the line oh you know what i have
something like the long jump line your
ankles i can always see that line
there's so many things to worry about in
my physical appearance my vpl
is just not highlighted what's a vpl
visible oh okay
i didn't realize it had a but so i asked
grace
to go grab me some underwear this is how
old she maybe thinks i am
or how unsexy she thinks i am i'm like
hey can you we were like in a super rush
i had to run to do a stand-up show we
were recording
who are recording uh jamie lee and grace
sewed two doilies together and brought
him up
i was like grace could you grab me
somebody brought four trolls she came
back it looks like just a giant
ace bandage or like seamless nude
they were they
yeah it was the cover to make sure dust
didn't get on it from the construction
i have a pro granny pants it was the
biggest pair of underwear i've ever seen
i don't
i think they were like spanx and i'd
love the idea of choosing this must be
what
i think they were spanx uh but yeah but
i had more full butt underwear in so
long
full bed underwear turns into a thong
within 10 seconds anyway
not if you're two strides not if you're
doing it right no not there's not
anything got no aids
no there's too much fabric to get up
there is it nice you safely put them to
your to your skin
not if they have um stirrups and i had
mine
do you remember stirrup leggings yeah
they're still things i used to wear
those
all the time stirrups they were there
were leggings that went down
when i was little yeah yeah okay well
that was not that long ago when i was
rude um i had some other things i want
to talk about we did our ancestry tests
we did
and i thought it'd be interesting for us
all to uh
uh everyone on the team here to give
away all their data
to the government so that we could uh
explore our ancestry my favorite thing
about paying for these is that it told
me important information like
there's a one percent chance that you
have red hair like one
mirror i also appreciated that also uh
benton's dyeing his hair a lot these
days there's a 99
chance that his hair will be red in the
next two weeks i'm like what
i discovered that i'm point four percent
finish
but my sister is not are you almost
finished it's weird because you never
have finished in bed
that's not true that's not my problem
that's the guy is that's how to finish
i'm a mayonnaise person uh i am 97.2
percent
northwestern european 97. i know mostly
brit i mean i'm translucent
whoa i'm 91 british and irish i'm 65
percent british and irish what was the
biggest surprise
eleven point eight percent i tell you on
oh that makes sense your mom's a talent
and then i'm oh
10.5 french in germany oh cool i'm 1.5
sardinian oh that you're a sardine i
know one of my ancestors
uh i'm eight point four percent
scandinavian that's what i thought i was
all irish that's right that stuff
doesn't really interest me but i love
all these like weird things that tell
you just say the interesting stuff like
the
this one tells you if you this isn't an
interesting thing make it interesting
we make boring mistakes this is tells
you one of the things on here that tells
you if you sneeze when you look at the
sun based on your genetics
but why is that helpful to us like and
let me tell you try it how do i find
that grace the stuff that oh scientific
details today
and i am less likely to sneeze when i
look at the sun
i'm less likely to get bunions by the
way anyone that looks into the sun
is missing a chroma they should just
like if you're looking in the sun you
are mentally
asparagus odor detector i am i am likely
to smell pee
or asparagus in my pee i'm more
neanderthal than my sister and sometimes
she just texts me that to remind me to
hurt my feelings only
uh someone with a lot of neanderthal
would pronounce it neanderthal
misophonia
teaching whitney the internet it's not
the internet it's a very confusing
website that i've never been on because
i didn't want to give all my data to the
government because i'm sure i have a
weird dui floating look here genetically
it'll tell you if you have a fear of
public speaking and
benten based on your genetics and other
factors you are less likely
more likely view eight reports from
wellness oh yeah okay
here uh alcohol flush reaction unlikely
to flush
great what caffeine consumption
likely to consume more that is
absolutely correct uh deep sleep
less likely to be a deep sleeper well
that's because i'm so drunk oh this says
i
i based on my genetics i have a slightly
higher than average odds of hating the
sounds of chewing
well that's who's your italian doesn't
really bother me i kind of like that
muscle composition
common in elite power that's what mine
says mine too that i believe i watch
benton kick over a mailbox in one try
once
uh when i had my what do i have into
when i had my my neck procedure done the
man was like wow a lot of this
is just muscle and i was like of course
it is it's great
so i have more neanderthal dna than 81
percent of other customers oh my god
that trash mine's 89. i'm 29.
i thought i was a high no you're very
low neanderthal
i thought i was high you're not i
thought i was basically
on the floor i think a lot of people
that to this podcast think you're high
all the time
being hurtful no this is we're in the
ring
we're in the ring i'm not really sure
what to do after we roast each other for
entire podcasts we all leave
i'm sorry i'm sorry and just cry and i'm
not really sure what this is this gave
me any health information at all
yeah i don't think it's great i i also
think it's like it's like
like this is like if they're not a
sponsor i just feel like so much health
is psychosomatic that if you tell me i'm
gonna get sick
i'm gonna manifest being sick you know
what i'm saying like i feel like so much
of getting sick is mental
your brain is so powerful and placebo it
is like placebo effect is an effect so i
don't want to
look at all these diseases they're going
to tell me i'm going to get has this
factored in for antibiotics and eating
healthy and like
yeah there's a whole there's reports on
every one of them what about your
cilantro guys do you like cilantro
oh because it tastes different to
different people i like it
i don't i don't like it and it says i
don't know i don't like it and i didn't
need you to tell me that sir exactly
same with the red hair yeah i could
figure out myself alcohol
flush reaction i just puke up my alcohol
like a lady yeah i'm on it like an adult
i just
spit it right back into the can and
throw it out the window drink it again
aaa likely to flush after drinking
alcohol ag likely to
flush i am gg no i'm unlikely to flush
after drinking
i have flesh a lot it says oh so it's a
big flusher so you can
you can tolerate a lot of alcohol yeah
it moves through you fast see this is
probably that's why
that's why i always get alcoholism in my
family you guys can't tolerate hold on
to it yeah
you guys love your advisors you know
they're really taking care of it we're
pickled i mean i'm
i am people ask me they're like why does
your skin looks good i think i'm
embalmed do you know what this should
actually be good for
giving it to someone else like me
reading yours yours reading mine would
be way more helpful than reading about
my own
i think so too because like me i'm just
like i
i don't i know all this mm-hmm and the
only thing i and i don't want to know
that i have more of whatever
that club oh but this is interesting to
know so people with
alcohol flush variant that's me unlikely
to flush drinking alcohol carries
additional health risks because their
bodies can't break down toxic substance
substance acid tala
sorry that's my neanderthal coming out
drinking alcohol carries health risks
well whoa the most useful thing on my
report is that
89 percent or more of my relatives were
likely to have worked as a lifeguard
well i am likely to be wait wait wait
wait is that real yep
get to know your relatives they are 89
more likely to have worked as a
lifeguard wait is this because
you they connected to your ancestors
online through this thing
i don't know 100 are british and irish i
have no idea i mean it's so strange i
don't know i mean if you i don't know
hold on if you live on the island of
ireland you're gonna have to save some
lives because it's surrounded by water i
mean that's like
i'm trying to figure it out 58 of my
relatives love to drink energy drinks
that is so crazy but we didn't answer
that 95
are more likely to have red body or
facial hair
are we related benjamin yeah a little
redhead no i have one percent
oh i thought it said you're more like
less likely you're you're more likely
i'm less likely to have that so
95 more likely to have red body or you
know your relatives
your relatives are i know but i'm saying
i don't have anything because you're
mostly british
that's why i'm just saying i i'm finding
out that i'm adopted and i didn't want
to find that out this way
oh uh maternal help bow group you also
have the darkest hair i've ever seen so
not right now not today i gotta go back
to brown soon
i really do watch people are getting
worried watching the clips when you have
brown hair is so
so weird to me yeah and all i've known
you so much longer with brown hair but
it's still so dark
thing about i think with my because look
the last couple months having covered
covered fog
i wouldn't look crazy on the edibles i'm
three days off edibles no edibles they
do not agree with me
benton is that in the report because i
don't believe it if it's not no ben
benton uh uh has seen me fall down a
flight of stairs
pass out in this podcast studio and hit
my head uh
it's it's just not a i just with the
pandemic was happening i was like i
should i'm too abstemious
the issue is whitney thinks edibles work
immediately upon arrival into your body
and i'm so impatient
and so she thinks that if it's been a
minute that they should be working and
it's like two hours
it's boring and then like 12 hit her at
one time no i'll take
one and in 10 minutes like my problems
aren't immediately gone
i'm like these are broken i got a dud
and then i'll take like
seven and then how long are they
supposed to what is what's the time
lapse
it's usually like 30 to 40 minutes
depending on if you've eaten something
already like you eat it on an empty
stomach you'll get higher faster but the
thing is with a lot of these edibles
like the um the way that it's
distributed is really uneven like
maureen dowd did like a whole thing on
this
because if like you have the blueberries
like read blueberries those were my
yeah no longer um now i'm just hard
kombucha
and um heroin uh
good stuff like but those things i can
actually manage like i've never had an
issue with
substances telling me to do really dumb
shit like take more of the substance
like my thing
like cigarettes my thing is i don't want
to be addicted to cigarettes because i
won't get as
high if i smoke them all the time like
the same thing with like alcohol i'm
like i just want
one glass so i can really feel it you
know what i mean and i don't want to get
my tolerance too high i mean that's a
ride or die addict right there someone
who's like i'm not gonna drink so i feel
the high even harder
right you know and so uh so with the
edibles i would take them and a lot of
times
the way they're cooked like they put the
thc in but they can't
control how much goes in each one so one
blueberry might have
30 milligrams and one might have two you
never really yeah so i in my head was
like ah i got one i get dud i'm gonna
take five
and then i start doing my own math i did
this is so embarrassing
i have no weed edibles the most
embarrassing things i've ever done on
wheat edibles
when i was in uh mexico
um that's the respectful way to say it
um
uh where was i i was at this place
called a monta i was michael patrick
king bridget everett was there bridget
the great bridget everett if you don't
know her google her right now god bless
yeah
brilliant performer i had had my ear
bitten off by a dog i didn't want to
take painkillers
i was like i'm not an addict right i'm
just gonna take 90 edibles right
they're natural they come from the earth
but i took i had no
idea how to like read the milligrams i
didn't really know the difference
between sativa indica like i'm just like
a bad
at drugs you'd think i know a ton about
most there's
weed never and i was at a new year's eve
dinner
i took a hundred milligrams of thc
because it came in a gummy like a
lot right yeah yes you're supposed to
divide it up into four
i just ate the whole thing i didn't know
um i was just with this like male model
i met on mariah
oh i felt a little too confident in my
choices and uh
wipe under your eyes i passed out at
the buffet on the beach new year's eve
buffet holding
a handful of salad in one hand
and a marrow bone in the other hand i
can find the photos of how fucking high
i was i passed out
and then bridget everett thought i was
like doing a bit
which is a testament to how fucking
annoying i am uh at social gatherings
she's i all i remember is watching her
step over me
and like walk away and i was like no one
can see me
i'm invisible but she just thought i was
doing a bit so she's just like haha and
just like kept walking to like take a
picture or something but i was like no i
could see me
oh no and then i kept standing up and
every time i stood up
um you know those like balloon people in
front of car dealerships
they go up and then they just go down
and they go like literally my knees just
would not hold my body and i kept
passing out in the sand michael patrick
king i mean one of my dearest friends
but also someone who's respect i'd like
to
keep uh literally they had to drag me
onto the beach and remove me
had they everyone done in the group too
like was it a group activity that no
that's all but that's the creepiest part
about it is that i'm not like let's all
party together i'm gonna
take so that i'm okay and then i'm like
oh
so high and then um when you're trying
to not
come off high you seem so high
have you been roofied because you're
literally just like hey man i have not
been roofied but i didn't
know of what yeah why who we were at a
bar in nashville andrew santino i knew
it no it's nobody that ever wanted to
roofie me
um i was at a bar in nashville and there
was
this there was this um
bartender that wanted to like sleep with
my friend
there were like 12 of us and i i am
notorious if you go anywhere with me
then at the party finish other people's
drinks i will
buy everyone's shots like to the point
where it is like let's go
bad like because they're like so fun to
shoot them together
yeah yeah it's only drinking two
together activity and so like there was
these drinks they're called death shots
in nashville they're probably other
places
and i ordered like 14 of them or
something and he
didn't know which one she was going to
get so he just roofied them all so the
only
people that didn't get roofie were the
two that set their drinks down and then
were nervous and didn't drink them
i took all my clothes off in the and got
on top of what
and got on top of the speaker in that
bar we have this one video this is on
video
[Music]
and then i puked they wouldn't let me in
the lift my friend had to call someone
to come get us
i was like i got and then i put all my
clothes back on and i got inside of them
like like
you couldn't see any of me and was talk
giving a whole i was it was very bad
um can i just say but super fine if i
were the girl i'd be so flattered that
someone wasted that many roofies just to
get one into my drink well what is hold
on let's break this down
is roofie quaaludes or is ketamine i
don't know what it is but i know that
all this was your body paralyzed
it was like it was like being blacked
out no it's like being i remembered
nothing like i apparently was
completely functioning but like all of
us that actually drank the drink
all of us had the same experience and it
was like it was like from the minute we
took that drink
how did you find out um well ma
the other girl she just said that's i
mean i guess we just found out my the
other girl had been roofied before and
she said that's what um so whenever we
described it
whenever she described it she like it
sounds like it sounds like you're
you were roofied and like because all of
us that took it the rest
immediately remember when it was like
nothing it was like the day did not
happen that's crazy
anything else we need to say before we
go go to get your tour tickets whitney
cummings.com
and get some merch before it's all gone
the merchant is up now
is going away for new merch to be fill
its place that hurts me
my heart well it can be reprinted okay
but
it is going away so collection coming in
[Music]
so it'll be here when it's here and we
do want you guys to make sure you're
getting the
other merch if you want it because it
will be gone when it's done now the
batbap sweatpants the tie-dye the one
with the brain on it the wild merch
everything you see on i love that guy
except for the white
good for you hoodie we'll be staying oh
the one with the orange that's the white
one that's like peach and white
yeah um i love you don't ride elephants
and here is paris hilton
ready oh my god you know what's so funny
is that i you're a nightmare
because i have to be next to you i was
trying so hard to look cute for you
didn't happen didn't pull it together
i never look i never feel um
less put together than when i'm with you
well you look like a little
sailor unicorn i look like a little
child
um that's about to go sit on santa's lap
and it's not gonna go
as planned um i
am sitting here with paris hilton how do
you feel
good are we friends yes we are friends
oh no i miss you i feel like we are
friends in a weird like metaphysical way
we haven't gotten to spend that much
time together yeah but
um we're very close on like a spiritual
level
i agree don't you think yeah we need to
hang out more why is that
i just feel like we're just we have
these fun personalities that just like
mesh well together but i i also but i
also might be delusional
i think i'm closer to you than i am
because i feel when i was in l.a and you
know
during the time when you were sort of
introduced to the world like
i was learning so much from you at the
time like
you were kind of all of our fairy
godmother
it was kind of like all of our like
fairy godmother older sister
cool older sister that was like dating
all the cool guys and
making these fashion choices i was like
just wear whatever pairs where's you
know you're like my
everyone's cool older sister for so long
do people feel
weirdly close to you i feel like people
feel like they know me just from
watching me grow up and
watching the simple life and just seeing
me in the media for so long
so a lot of times when i meet people
they'll sometimes know more about me
than i even know about myself
right oh that's the worst like i'll be
walking through the airport and so i'm
gonna be like
like yellow joke of mine i'm like ew
gross you know what i mean
and they're like it's your joke and i'm
like oh sorry i forgot about it
like like do you ever look back at them
and go like uh
wish i hadn't uh sometimes some of the
stuff
just on that show i was just acting like
such a dumb blonde that i look back on
it now what is
what is the dumb blonde thing we were
just talking about this what what is
that
i i'm obsessed with getting granular
about
what is the origin of dumb blonde joan
of arc was blonde
right wasn't um amelia earhart maybe
blunt like why
dumb blonde marilyn monroe is that when
it started
probably i think it's just always been a
stereotype and
back when i was just coming into the
industry it was like almost like it was
cute to be that
you know who ruined it nazis
yeah she literally i feel like perizone
has a little button
that's just like a publicist button
where just an ejector button where
she'll just
if i say something that could her entire
global
uh empire she just disappears into thin
air
um what is going on in terms of like
this is a
press tour you're on i'm not gonna ask
you questions that you normally get
asked
when i watch your interviews it it
frustrates me
why because i'm just watching you and
i'm like why like
i can't tell if you want if you're in
control of what you're revealing
do you know what i'm saying or if you
look how long she'll not talk like
you'll just shy
you are shy it's so weird what do you
mean you're shy
i don't know i've just always been a
very shy person which a lot of people
don't believe but i am
i i believe it and there's this thing
with you where i'm like
when i see you out and when i and i
watch your documentary
i'm like i have compassion for you and
then i see you and i'm like i don't feel
sorry for you
you're so strong you have such like
strong energy
and you claim your space so hard and i'm
just dying to know
how you sit there and don't say anything
look
that's what i need to learn how to do
look at her i think that's called
self-esteem
how did you get it how'd you get it
where'd you get um
i don't i think just from going through
so much in my life that maybe
it's just it's not that it's self-esteem
i think it's just this thing that i have
it's hard to describe like i don't know
it's a stoic
like is there a conscious effort to
allow people
to just project
because there's something about like
like if you can't approve upon silence
just don't say anything
because i look at you and i'm like that
is so smart just say
just don't say anything if you don't say
anything they can't get you
what are they gonna get you know what
i'm saying you're like uncancelable
because you
weren't like that me
i cannot keep my mouth closed it's so
powerful is this conscious
was it taught i just don't how i've
always been
i never even think about it it just
happens what about for you you just
always talk
i mean kinda it's like i just um
i'm so impressed by you because i think
there's this right now or in this moment
where we're like okay
fame business women running how much do
we owe
our fans how much what is privacy how
much are you going to show how much are
you going to keep for yourself
you know i think we're in that place and
i feel like it's a comedian it's like we
can share everything in podcasting we
have to share everything and here's my
breakfast and
i just you know got this and i i'm on
this anti-depressant and i'm on the head
this uti
you know but like where do you draw the
line in terms of privacy
i feel you know now with social media
and everything it's just like this whole
new world where everyone is
sharing everything and i think there is
people who just definitely over share
and with me i like to share my life and
before i only showed a certain part
and now i'm sharing a lot of things that
i'd never discussed before which
helps other people to understand and
relate to that they go through the same
things
so i've never been so open in my life
have been in like the past
year since the documentary came out are
you allergic to anything
no nothing you have zero allergies
zero zero
yeah why i've never heard that before
that's amazing
yes i'm just trying to i'm i'm only
asking you questions you have not been
asked before
because you are have been asked every
question and it makes me so
why do you do interviews why are you
here
well i'm here because i love you and
that'd be fun and i love your podcast
and um i do interviews because i have to
for work
it's just part of like the contracts and
you're just yeah you're obligated
mostly she's like i'm here because i'm
obligated
but it's like but you are um so clear
about your business
you know and it's something that i
admire so much like you're so what
drives you
do you think it's ancestral because of
what you come from like
business is in your blood it's in your
dna it's in your bones
is it like i i believe i have something
to prove i have something to prove
and i'll what drives me is i want to
change the whole structure of how this
works
to make it fair and right so that
everyone else can you know
like i'm trying to figure out what
drives me like what drives you every day
i think just from growing up in my
family it was a lot to live up to
and something just that runs in my jeans
and my blood
and also just wanting to prove myself i
didn't want to be known as
paris hilton the hilton hotel
granddaughter i wanted to be known as
paris
so i've always just worked so hard to
just make my own name for myself
what's your middle name whitney what
is that true is that real yeah
paris whitney hilton so are we related
yes behind the wheel i didn't even think
about this until now too oh my god
that's crazy
i'm that's wild so am i somehow
royalty i just will get my lawyer
we'll we'll talk later um i watched
okay so the documentary i know everyone
there's a there's a narrative that
that um you know on our podcast there's
clickbait and then there's stuff we like
to cover
i always have a different takeaway so
that was you know the documentary's
incredible
super powerful there's a moment when
you're
about to dj at about badland outside
lands
tomorrowland tomorrowland i am so bad at
festivals it's
just i'm not cool enough and i and i
boycott the name of festivals i'm like
bout to bumper shoot
but coachella belt and i like i refuse
to learn them because i
hate uh that i can't get the wristband i
want um
and i saw you and your in the your dude
at the time
no i was not my dude it was just some
random some random
and uh uh he will i can't wait till he
sues me
after i say this but um i was like shit
dude
we've all been there when you're in a
relationship
with a guy and you're about to shine or
a girl or whatever like we've all been
in relationships that like
thwart us in some way and we're trying
so hard to give them everything
and shine and find that balance and that
was that was really hard for me to watch
can you just like describe that moment
that was a nightmare because it was you
know one of the biggest shows i've ever
played in my life this is tomorrowland
it's
the biggest music festival in the world
half a million people
and he was just being so annoying and
just like
why are you promoting these other people
and not promoting me it was just like
gross and then
dropping my computer and just completely
stressing me out right before i had to
get on stage it was just
i couldn't take it anymore so i was like
you have to go but
that is it was such an important moment
for i think everyone to see is like
we're all
hustling we're all trying to elevate but
the person you pick
is a business decision i'm saying you
know i mean
it's a business so it's like business
woman the person you decide to marry
the person you partner with is a
business choice and i remember liking
that and going like
it really um made me think about all the
times that i've been like
game time about to do something
important and i'm like and then my
personal life
undermined me you know so like what when
do you feel like you learned that your
personal life and your professional life
like
they they are not inseparable yeah that
was definitely a big moment
and this was something i didn't want the
world to see
like i was fighting with the director
like please cut that out like i did not
want that in there i don't even want
this
loser like getting any attention like
just cut him out of the whole film
and she was like no i need to show that
that you're taking back your power
and you know there's you've had enough
and this is the first time that you've
really done that because i never have
stuck up for myself like that ever
um so this is just like the beginning
and then what like
like what um when you have conflict in
relationships like how do you
manage that you don't seem like you like
love conflict i hate it
i hate confrontation i hate conflict
yeah any time i've had like an issue
with someone i
don't say anything and i just stop
talking to them and dump them
but i can't even you're a ghoster you're
a yeah
i think if if something if i feel like
you're not hearing what i'm saying i
just remove myself from the situation
and try to regroup
yeah i'm like that too i just can't i
don't even
wanna dignify it with a response i don't
wanna get into it i'm just like peace
that's so healthy where did you learn
that just from
life god i think just from going through
hell and back because just
out left and right yeah especially in
this town
do you feel like i was i was thinking
about you this morning all i do is think
about you
um and i was like what what have you
learned
from about human nature it
being a boss and now that you you know
have all these businesses what have you
learned about human nature like what do
you think is like
cut and dry human nature and what's
changeable about human nature like are
we inherently
um wired to want to see someone get
destroyed
i'm not but i feel like there are a lot
of people who are who love that
and it makes me sad that people
just enjoy watching people get torn down
or
just even watching the brittany movie
that just made me just feel so emotional
and
just to see just how people and the
media and just how the way she was
treated and
so it could relate to that in a lot of
ways i was talking to laura wasser
um she was in the podcast recently and
how do we get
brittany out is someone who do you have
her number do we call her now
like it's just uh saga
it's really just it's so sad just to be
an adult and have worked your entire
life and then just be treated like a
child and
she just has no freedom are there things
that you've seen
like because i like to go like now that
i'm like oh i get to like build my own
version of this business you know
and i look back at all the things that
didn't work like there was i mean i used
to go to auditions and
hotels i used to go on like i was
telling people the other day like
for the first five years of my career i
was just going on dates with agents
i thought there were meetings like i
just
i didn't know i thought that like caa
was just at chateau marmont like i don't
know
like i'm just going you know what i'm
saying like are there things that you're
like that was not right that was like
you know looking back and things that
you want to course correct moving
forward as you build your business
um i never went on dates with agents
you're like um i exclusively date uh
celebrities icons
um although we do have a little bit of
beef because you did date um the love of
my life eddie furlong
so paris hilton has a podcast and i was
on it the other day and she's like who's
your childhood crush
um and i was like i had photos of eddie
for a long
truly like floor to ceiling like i would
make
like i would lick my wall and pretend we
were making out when i was like 10 years
old that's hot
and you dated him for how long i don't
remember
i was like 18. i think it was like nine
months or something
my dream guy is like you're sort of like
throwaway guy it was a long time ago
so i feel like such a big part of like
what you know as
as women now is just like pass on
whatever we learned men women anyone
um like what do you feel like
you would like to pass on to the people
starting businesses
now that are what do you wish was
available to you when you're in your 20s
early 20s just now it's just amazing how
much is available to people
like just with even a social media
platform
come on let's drink a little water oh my
gosh paris drinks water you guys okay
water
yes um just the tools that they have
nowadays
are just you know you could basically
make an entire career just
off having a phone and a talent and you
know that wasn't possible back then
so i just think it's really incredible
with technology
what people can do nowadays and so and
you also
i feel like came up around so much fame
that was so
um traumatizing like you know like your
family you grew up around famous people
jim says you know you saw how
is it is it healthy is this healthy
like i feel like you have managed to
figure it out and i don't know if it's
because you grew up in it and it's like
kind of you're used to it you know how
to protect yourself you have boundaries
but like is it healthy to be famous like
what precautions do we need to take as
we're all going
i want to be famous i want to be rich
and then we get there and it's like
it's a mental it's a really challenging
mental health thing
i feel lucky i think just from having a
supported family
and really growing up in this town and
just seeing it all
where i've just kept like a level head
on my shoulders
but then i see other people just
just crash and burn and i've seen it all
i've seen so many people come and go and
it's
really detrimental to mental health i've
just
you know the pressures of it and
everything and the people
that you meet and getting over there's
just so much that comes with it
but i've been through so much that
nothing bothers me
what scares you does anything scare you
death
that's so scary i just because i don't
know what happens after us and if it's
nothing and that'd be
the most boring thing in the world so
boring
i'm so scared of that like i hope it's
somewhere like amazing and like fun and
i was i can't believe that i was
thinking about that i was like what if
we just die and all this work i did on
this podcast studios for nothing
you know what i mean when you're like
working hard for something you're like
what's it all for so yeah that is a fear
my fear isn't dying like getting hurt in
the shark
it's more all the work i did is for
nothing then nothing
after that did you have religion growing
up
i went to catholic schools yeah oh
that'll do that'll do it
and so we um i'm obsessed with when
uh someone has found their person
and has kissed you know found their
prints kissed the frogs
or some like red flags like like
absolutely
paris hilton wisdom like if you see a
guy do this
girl do this whatever on a date red flag
like rude to wait staff huge red flag i
hate that where's abercrombie and fitch
huge red flag yeah like when people are
rude to people i
like that that's just a turn off
and how they are with their phone
i think that's a big red flag like if a
guy is weird about his phone and like
always is hiding it or like putting it
on like airplane mode because they don't
want text coming through or
if you like try to like touch it they
like have a panic attack
things like that scare me so i think
it's important just to do
like your spy work and like research and
make sure that you're just not going to
get
over because if you're not careful
guys can take advantage and they will
have you like
have you ever been wrong i'm saying
because it's like when you're like
pin my stomach every time that happens
i'm like i knew it
six months later i knew it my gut has
never been wrong
i always uh try to talk myself out of my
intuition you know the first time you
see him flip his phone over boom
and you're gonna pin your stomach you
have all the information you need
you know i really believe that that you
will
that thing over there what your like
word head thing
i saw your video of it what head that
that's a robot
i know i love it i saw the video you did
with it it was dying
keep looking at it i'm like your evil
twin
i know this is the evil twin that's the
nice one the robot is the one that
you'd want to hang out with um and uh uh
you know because it's like it's it's
it's this weird thing where i'm
struggling
how do you manage being a businesswoman
i mean
you said something in that documentary
it took me so long to learn this
when uh the random dude who was sort of
sabotaging your big moments
it was very clear to me now as a as an
adult woman that's been in therapy for
15 years and 12 step programs i'm like
oh he was insecure and he was
trying to make it about him you said in
that moment you were like
you're so insecure you know how
how do you do you ever have to make
yourself
feel like you have to make yourself
smaller minimize yourself make yourself
quote-unquote beta for your pers or have
you met the person where you're like i
can just be whoever the
me yeah before it would be just very
emasculating to a man
just they would just turn and just so
insecure
and just like couldn't handle being with
a powerful woman and that's what i've
dealt with forever
until now like my fiance is on my level
we're equals
he wants to empower me to be the best
woman i can be and
equals partners yeah that's so dope
so happy like i can't believe it and so
like what about him is there's something
it's so interesting it's like i always
say it's like it's not about how
who he is it's about how you feel when
you're with the person so like i'm
dating this dude now who it's just like
all he wants to do is like solve
problems and i'm like
oh maybe this is love like when you just
feel relieved all the time
mm-hmm what i'm saying because i
realized in relationships before i was
like
who's he texting is he gonna be mad if i
do this do i have to tell them about
this oh that gives me like goosebumps
just worry oh the worst just the
constant
you're my nightmare i watch an interview
between you guys and he was just like
this carter carter had a spell's last
name
rheem this guy these beat
he's got us he's on point i'm like that
is it that's her equal
he's incredible like i feel like he's
like god like sent me this angel to come
and save me from
all these losers but what um
what when did you know with him when did
you know
because sometimes when the right guy
comes along we and we sabotage ourselves
and we put all our past baggage onto
them and we ruin it
yeah we've seen it happen you're not
gonna do that
no we've known each other for 15 years
and oh i didn't know that
yeah so we've been friends forever and
then um on thanksgiving i went to the
hamptons with my family
and we just we're having lunch together
and we just like connected and then that
night we had dinner
had our first kiss and then right when
we had the kiss i was like
i'm in love with this guy and this is
what i want to be with and i think i was
just so sick of every
all the other been throws like i just
want something real
and i was ready an adult he's just like
a grown ass adult
yeah i was like this guy has like a 401k
i was like this motherfucker like he's
got like you know what i mean like
um and then when did you say i love you
did he say first
i think we both said we said at the same
time after a couple days we like went to
miami for art basel
and we were just making out and jinx
said it
it was cute um how long
when should someone say i love you
what's too soon i think there's no time
frame on it yeah it's just
love like it's suppose if it's meant to
be yeah
it will happen right away if you say it
too soon
and it's weird it's not meant to be
right
like anything awkward like do you feel
like things that annoy you in past
relationships
when carter does it it's not annoying no
you're right
nothing nothing nothing nothing
and then once you're um uh when you guys
have a conflict
do you ever have conflicts no we never
argue about anything
it's crazy because i'm used to being in
like crazy relationships where it's like
always drama always fighting always
being scared
always being untrusting and with this
i'm just i've never felt so safe
and secure and i have nothing to worry
about and it's just like
how is this even real it's crazy i'm
always just trying to figure like does
relationships take work are they
supposed to be easy like i'm always
trying to like figure it out because
it's like when things are hard
everyone's like well relationships they
work
and then people go it should be easy it
should be effortless and i'm like i can
never figure it out so we're always sort
of talking about that on this
do a little both yeah do you eat jelly
beans
do i eat them sometimes depends on the
flavors are these like weird flavors
so these are um jelly belly benton will
you explain this to me
they're jelly belly beanboozled beans so
they could be a delicious flavor
or a terrible flavor that's what i
thought i knew that you would have those
weird ones
i want to go through red flags or like i
want to um
i want to just do some like i just feel
like you find this prince
i'm like i just wanna all the girls
listening all the guys listening i just
want to like
bestow all the wisdom learn from our
mistakes learn from our mistakes we made
them
you were making them in a mansion at the
same time i was making them in a studio
apartment um we just we were making the
same mistakes just very different
um parking situations i had to go get
like a parking pass it was a nightmare
um and then why don't we do whoever gets
a bad one
gives a piece of relationship advice
okay i feel like the brown ones are bad
and it
tastes like poop they're all okay so
this one
doesn't matter what color it is to know
which one it was
the jelly belly box oh god they're
giving me um okay so jelly belly
okay so so don't look at it or don't you
can't look it up shit sorry
i'm so um bad at jelly beans um uh
what's this one what color is that pink
pink and
flecks of benton what is this yellow
fruity
tutti frutti but i don't like tutti
frutti when it's not a sneaky
flavor i'm sorry
this one all right on there
oh no she got it i think she got it
this one tastes like throw up what color
was it
purple or pink and blue give her a good
one give her that
wait give her a good one we don't know
which one is good that's the point of
the game
what was that one supposed to be the
purple and or pink and blue that was
insane that one tastes like throat so it
was actually
dead fish dead fish and then the blue
one
and then and then you had a blue one
after that yeah like mint
that's toothpaste so it's also
toothpaste perfect cleanse it out
but i like that you told your composure
so well we did not
it was like a really cute color so i was
expecting it to be like cotton candy or
something nice
oh this is a metaphor for life
to me this is like a complete metaphor
for life sometimes things come in cute
packaging
the ins you know what i'm saying yeah
like this is a metaphor sometimes the
oh wait so who gives the advice me or
her whoever got the bad one you said
whoever got the bad one okay did you eat
one
yeah didn't i yeah yeah yours was like
good
it was good and then i was panicking
here you can get another one throw up
one
okay you know what that one is this is
birthday cake i think isn't this a bunch
of different ones
this is the key you tell us this is
tutti frutti or stinky socks
that one's bad i hope it's stinky socks
for you
after what i just said that's the one i
got the other day that was really
traumatic stinky socks
yeah benjen almost fell off a ledge when
he ate one of these
oh my god that's not even like actually
that might be
too intense that's too much that's not
that shouldn't be legal
i'm so sorry okay your drink is spilling
all over the floor
so you're the other side of where oh
so dumb um whoever thought of that like
do they think of these for people who
like want to joke with their friends or
just to be serious
so it comes with a game and you spin it
like twister but then you have to pick
um okay so i'll get so you give a piece
of relation advice i'll give a piece of
relation of advice we both got a bad one
um i uh
always ask is it worth it someone once
said to me
i was in this like really stress like
relationship is like so hard and he just
goes
is it all worth it and i was like oh my
god
no like the good times didn't outweigh
the bad times but i was so addicted to
the adrenaline and the chaos
and you know when you're like in
something bad and you're just in it and
to get
out of it would actually be harder than
to you know say
you know when somebody's like i guess
i'll just stay in this because like
we're on a trip next month and we
already booked that flight so let me
just like stay in the
like just get out as soon as you're
thinking about breaking up you're gonna
break up
that's my advice i don't think i have
ever thought about breaking up with
someone
and it didn't you know what i'm saying
yeah well it didn't happen obviously
i agree with that and just not wasting
your time because life is so short and
so precious and like
i've wasted years of my life with people
who didn't deserve my time
so i feel like you said when you have a
bad feeling or something happens
don't give them the second chance
especially if it's something that
because once they do it once that's just
like how they are the way you do
anything is the way you do everything
yeah like that's your nature i got your
nature and now it's up to me whether i'm
going to be in denial about it or not
exactly you know let me see the ring
jerk so
so question so carter so
his proposal i've i've i look i have
some ideas for the wedding
mm-hmm i officiate
loves that that's pretty much the main
that's the idea
that's the pitch are you talking about
it how are we planning it yes
does every woman uh grace and i were
just does everyone
have their wedding dress in their head
since they're a kid
because we were both like i fully have a
wedding dress just on deck
not even engaged i always had like
the disney princess vibe of a dress just
like
like looking at like cinderella or
something like that
but now it's it's changed like i want
something just more like elegant
and yeah and then where
that's what i'm trying to figure out
it's like a legal issue of mine to ask
what is it
somewhere like nice and warm nice or not
too warm because i hate when you're at a
wedding and it's just like hot and humid
and gross
so somewhere with like california
weather because it's just
but how many p you have too many i know
that's
it's like i'm stressed out about your
wedding for you
yeah i am too because i know like
thousands of people
but with this world we're living in now
and i don't want to have to wait till
the world's completely open because
who knows when that will be mm-hmm and
then honeymoon like because here's the
thing i'm fascinated by you because it's
like you've been ever you've done it
like how is carter like how do i dazzle
this gal
that's been dazzled seen everything done
everything like i love that he's not
intimidated by that
he takes me to romantic places i've
never been before like napa and things
like that and like bora bora
we because usually for work i've always
had to dj or
travel and it was like ibiza or vegas or
miami or
is that how it's pronounced ibiza ibiza
okay
thank you i need a rich famous bra how's
can is it can
can can okay thank you but people say it
differently sometimes
like i hate when people say ibiza i
think it's so annoying
but some europeans say it like that but
i'm not into that
um so i've only been to like all like
these party islands and party
destinations and now i'm like an adult
so
he's taking me to like romantic places
that i never would have went before
because there's no clubs with them
and also i haven't been there with you
you know what i'm saying like i'm
starting to learn that because i'm
dating a guy who's younger than me and
like
i've been through the ring you know i've
been through i've dated it's not my
first rodeo
jim saying but there's a way to make
your second or third or
whatever rodeo i'm on it's fine it
doesn't have to be the
place we've never been you know what i'm
saying like i think sometimes our
our our perfectionist visions you know
as a as a business
person creep into our personal life and
undermine us sometimes
you know it's like we don't need our
personal lives to be as
prolific as our professional lives and
like uh grandiose
you know well plus when you've probably
been it's always been for work so you
only see
the hotel room and then wherever you're
going for the work so
that's so true yeah when you travel i've
been everywhere and i've literally seen
nothing because
i've been just in a hotel room or the
club or wherever i'm at for my event but
that's about it
right and then i was so do you have
someone in your life that's like
your person you're like that's your
nikki probably you know to make a
like big decision who do you go to my
sister
yeah she's a beast dude i've all i've
always just been like
like she's just got beast energy yeah
like i've i always felt like paris is
okay
like nicki will cut a bitch yeah like
she just has that energy
she's a boss have you guys ever gotten
in like fight fights
not like fight fights but just when i
was like little i would sometimes just
take her clothes and not ask yeah
she would like get mad normal but the
lateness thing i was thinking about too
excited in the documentary there's
something about that
b there's something about
that little hit of chaos before she was
trying to figure it out what do you
think it is
i think just being an aquarius i'm just
like very
floaty and also purses are tiny purses
are too small yeah
in my 80d i think i just are you on
something for that
no no like that's the other thing is
that i went to um
this doctor the other day i was like i
have anxiety and i'm on this and i'm on
and should i and he's like but isn't it
working for you
he kind of was like aren't some of these
things actually do you want to solve
these problems
you know because you're you're probably
like i'm doing this business and this is
probably part
makes you i think it's a superpower
super power turning your
um at things that are normally
pathologized into superpowers i
love yes emily i'm hungry i'm busy
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm very busy but what did you just see
me eat
whitney just sat down for a booking
meeting with a jar of peanut butter
and nothing else just a jar of peanut
butter
it's not peanut butter it was peanut
butter banana chocolate
goo it was a mix it needed a knife or a
spoon
and we just used our little finger and
then what did you say you said i said
that's disgusting and then you said get
some bread
and i did and then what happened then
you ate a
piece of bread which i ate i put the
peanut butter on the bread
as you instructed me to right because
you were being a bully
right oh that's me and then i ate it
and it was just the corner of it was the
same color as her hair
but we've all been blinded to that mold
color because we're staring at it all
day
every day so i ate a fully moldy piece
of bread this is what happens
when you don't use daily harvest when
you're left to your own devices is a 38
year old mentally ill woman
and you're busy and you eat moldy bread
you don't have to live like that you
could be eating daily harvest
flatbreads instead they're fresh healthy
no mold in sight nope except yeah they
deliver delicious food
all built on organic fruits and
vegetables right to your door
my favorite smoothies of theirs are mint
cow cow cacao
i love the flavor combinations i'm
always like like coriander yeah
yeah i don't know what that is but it is
delicious and then i like the staples i
like banana greens i like ginger
banana greens i feel like when i when i
make that as a smoothie sometimes i like
put a little olive oil in it that's just
me
and a little coconut oil huh i do go a
little rogue and i like add stuff
but it's all the fresh fruit all the
veggies all the stuff is already in
there so easy and you you can
just take the cup right to your car the
cup already has a hole in it
for the straw they thought of everything
everything
daily harvest never uses preservatives
added sugar or artificial anything
and they most recently launched their
almond milk spelled
m-y-l-k which is made of only almonds
and a dash of sea salt and that is it
and it's super convenient because i'm
always stocked up whenever i want to
make my smoothies
daily harvest is an undeniably delicious
clean food
without the prep get started today go to
dailyharvest.com
enter promo code good for you and get 25
off your first box that's promo code
good for you for 25
off your first box at dailyharvest.com
dailyharvest.com don't be silly
emily yes i love you thank you
but why are you talking to me and not
a therapist right now my depression has
depression
and i don't even want to leave my house
to find one
you um have been to a lot of therapists
in your day
quite a bit um have you asked them for
refunds or
they don't do that they really don't
they really don't
and when they're done when that 45
minutes is up you're
that it's over there's no
like wiggle room right 45 minutes right
and there's a
i i don't like going to the therapist
office oh i don't know first of all they
put all this stuff on the table
which is a trick i don't like the double
door
because where's your therapist in a
saloon
no like the double door to for the
patients that can't hear you in the
oh so that they can't hear you aiming
and crying right what i've never had a
double door
therapist yeah and then you know you
have to put on the straight jacket and
then you sit down
you know they buzz you in you know they
buzz away and they lay you down
and then they put the shot in your arms
every week look at those seat belts over
your chest
and the priest comes in your mom told
you that was therapy yeah yeah
totally i just think in person therapy
it's over there's got to be a better way
what it's called what a great segway
thank you
it's better help better help will assess
your needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist
on the internet so you can go the place
that you get
your mental trauma is the same place you
can heal your mental trauma now
perfect the internet two windows open
you can go on
instagram on one window and then open up
better on the other side and it'll
cancel each other out
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online
i think my favorite part is that um as
someone that has
needed to contact a therapist and get a
session immediately
this isn't like a hey i need to i can
see you in three weeks right
right they can you can start
communicating in under 48 hours that's a
game changer
yeah it literally was like i'm having a
crisis i can't stop dating married
narcissist
right and they're like okay we can see
you in four months by that time you're
married
yeah by that time yeah we're gonna walk
down the aisle exactly this podcast
is sponsored by better help and good for
you listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
whitney betterhelp.com
whitney that's t e r h
e l p dot com slash whitney i don't know
if you guys know this
but my first the first time i ever paid
off my loans
was um uh because a little show called
my new bff paris still did my new bff
the finale hired me to
i don't even know what i got to go back
i was like a writer on the finale
for writing like my jokes or other
people's but there weren't any jokes
were there i think it was like
transition i think i was writing
they hired me just to be there and then
the contestants
would come to me and i'd be like just
say this and they'd be like cool i was
like i don't even know why i'm here
i feel like i owe you money you guys
paid me like 20 grand it was the most
money i'd ever made at the time and i
was like sure
i'll do this i was like 25 i had no idea
what i was doing
did i ruin your show no that's so funny
though
so yeah if you were like uh had budget
issues
i'm the one that was taking money and
doing absolutely nothing but um but i
remember you on that subbing just so
kind to everyone and so
sweet like how do you um move through
people that need so much from you
and not take all that on i would watch
people just like
and you just have this like uh orb
around you
really yeah i don't i never really even
thought about it
i've just always been myself and i just
feel like when you're kind and you're
sweet and you're a good person
that you just get blessed in life and
have a good
good karma that is such a dope way to
put it
ben 10 are we going to play some games
with paris hilton yeah because
periscon's in my house i feel like i
have a giraffe in my house like i feel
like i have an exotic
like a rare exotic animal not yes i
guess a unicorn giraffe unicorn like
you had to drive at your house she'd be
very upset there'd be a news story
that's right i would be tweeting about
it malibu safari wine safari
um okay so because paris is um the
your business brain is just wild and i'm
you know for me i i don't i'm pretty
good at business
but you have this ability to go like
this is what's going to happen
i don't think people understand that
when you make a fragrance it takes so
much time
you have to stay committed to it you
have to follow through you have to see
it over the finish line
you have to yourself stay invested
how do you know like because there are
other times you're like oh just i wanna
this isn't even worth it it's taken two
like how do you know and have you ever
given up on something
in a good way and been like you know
this isn't worth it we're not gonna make
that
um i'm not a quitter i just i never stop
i have like this drive and determination
and i have good instincts so i
and i know what i want so
yeah i mean i i'm literally in therapy
to think the way you think
it's like it's actually frustrating how
clear you are like if someone asked me
that question
i'd have like a two hour answer i'd be
like so my ancestors like
you're just so clear benton
what's your game what's the first game
we're gonna do you have them oh i've got
all our games okay so we're gonna
use your business brain to build our
business okay
um no we're gonna see if any of our the
catchphrases that have uh
come from our show if you think any of
them have uh
the staying powers okay okay they're
worth trademarking
we've been on so many trademark calls oh
my god and
we get on trademark calls and i'm just
i've no i i have no idea what they're
saying yeah and not a clue it's like a
different language
it's a completely different language i'm
just like can you trademark it or not
yes or no and here's a hundred thousand
dollars and i have no idea what rights i
have
um okay first one first slogan
for paris hilton what do you think what
is it
like what i i you always have that
played like
on your instagram yeah um
you're doing it i think it's
no not to be trademarked no because it's
just like
noises yeah they're utterances
they're glutteral just i mean i was on
nyquil
peeing in my yard when i came up with it
so i don't know why it wouldn't be a
a hit a hit okay this is holding okay
second slogan
oh here we go sweet box
i wish it was sweet bomb so much better
than the one we have
sweet boy sweet boy that's benton that's
what i say before i say something mean
because i'm a sweet boy but that's cute
because you're sweet right shit you get
a point okay
no not the competition
study study and what is that for daddy
this is like
see i'm terrible at branding because i
this is something my dad used to always
say to me when things would get crazy
i just go steady steady like when people
and then uh walker dad had to train her
through it
and i would say steady and i was like oh
that's my and then i say it but it's not
catching on why not
it's yeah it's not really that catchy
it's like you're telling someone to like
chill and it's like when people do that
it's annoying
yes and you know what's weird i'm saying
it to myself
you can't have a catchphrase for
yourself yeah i'm saying it's a mantra
it's a mantra shit okay i'm lure okay
okay okay here's
um rock in a river
it's supposed to be a rock in a river
like a rock and a river would be a rock
and roll don't get it
it's too long maybe this is something
better than my mom said to me whenever
things are going really bad instead of
panicking she's like being a rock in a
river let it wash over you
okay so see here's the thing you don't
see he hates it mom
see i'll force the issue you just go
what's working and you'll let it
you'll let it take flight instead of
forcing
something that's not what i'm saying so
you just said that's hot people started
saying you're like oh that's the thing
you just listen to the metrics in the
fans and you could just say it for
anything like even if something's not
hot
like that's hot or just like there's
like a positive way to say it
like a negative way to say it there's
just it goes with everything
i don't know i just say it all the time
it's hot um and we also
you have how many fragrances 29
can you name them all yes really
i don't want to put you on the spot but
that is incredible thank you
can you name them all i can name a
couple
benton is never not wearing pepperoni
for men yes i do love the original paris
hilton for
him yes yeah the blue bottle it's so
good
i love it it's insane what is seven guys
wear that and what is the process like
what is
if you're if you're gonna make a
fragrance so because every celebrity
they get famous and then they have a
fragrance and it's always like that's
always
what's the process do you get to go in
because we want to make one for good for
you and you're going to help us
well basically you either go to like a
factory
or they can just have them delivered to
you just all these different notes and
scents
and then you pick your favorite one and
then from there
what i do is then i think of a name and
then start designing the bottle
and then come up with a campaign of what
it's going to be that like represents
the bottle and the name
and then it comes out so if you're going
to do one
for this incredible energy that you're
taking in now so if we did a good note
what would the notes be
uh puke what was that dirty socks
so far what notes have you picked up on
uh construction
construction work something turquoise
turquoise that for some reason like
turquoise and neon
like because this is very creative this
is very visual it has to live forever
like you have
what 29 fragrances that have to live
forever yes yes yes yes and benton is
such a genius at this stuff like
you know in working in retail he's like
no one buys that this is why people buy
this like the psychology of why people
buy like you're so good about going like
i'm gonna make something special that
someone's gonna want in their home
and i'm not good at that i'm working on
that you know but so okay so we're doing
for good for your fragrance we're doing
what else those are jokes but let's do i
love roses
like do you start there do you literally
just start there yeah like what notes do
you like like which
what perfume did you wear in high school
can i guess
ck one i love to see kayla that was my
shit
yes lolita
and then i wore paris hilton air i wore
lolita lympica
and then when i was feeling real crazy i
wore candy cane love sets
yes i wore calyx i was a dork i wore
tresor
by lancome are these words
i'm having a stroke um yeah and then
just naming dinosaurs well i'm just
thinking
i'm just saying like maybe you start
with perfumes you already like you know
what i'm saying
so you're like me cat i want to make
elizabeth arden sunflowers you know
that's my
i wore that one black diamonds
um so would you start there you would
just be like okay there's uh
this is what i do like i like kai i like
child i like you know this is
a fragrance i do like do you start there
or no yeah it's good to make a mood
board
of things that you like so that when
they do bring in the new sense they're
like okay we're going to bring something
that will remind you of that
so it's like being inspired so i didn't
even think of that
is that like plagiarizing sense i didn't
know that yeah you can probably
you can't go i want to smell like this
you want it to have like your own twist
on it otherwise people are going to say
oh she just copied this one
and then what are the things that you
say like that you're not in like
like business opportunities that come to
you and you're like not doing that
like not interest or not now because
someone like you it's not about if
you're gonna do it it's about when
you're gonna do it
are there things you're like just not
now you know
yeah there's been a lot of things that
have came in that i'm just like
not now or ever
um the weirdest thing anyone offered me
was
my own paris hilton sex dolls i was like
dude i am not doing that like that's
psychotic
so that was like the creepiest thing
anyone has ever offered
because what we say no to kind of
defines us too yeah i was like
is there i always wanted growing up
being a fan of you i always wanted a
paris hilton
x mcdonald's collaboration like what did
you order off the menu because i
remember growing up and seeing all those
like photos of you like going to the
drive-thru and people were like wow
cheats at mcdonald's i love mcdonald's
that's what you need a menu paris hilton
did you order oh my god that was
what was your order what didn't i order
um just like lots of fries
sweet and sour sauce chicken mcnuggets
chicken sandwich and then i'm obsessed
with the breakfast i just had it like
two days ago i had like
the pancakes the sauce so yeah and the
egg mcmuffins and
hash browns see we could get all this in
a little pink bottle
yeah there would be one of those
clippings there are those clippits you
used to put a half let's play
30 seconds of a song in you could bring
those back i like it
oh wait you know i'm not gonna forget to
do this i want to look at your most
recently used emojis
you can't change them you can't change
them you cannot change them
how about you do that you just go to
your texts
and go to your emojis
and you uh like you're about to send a
text and just screen grab
uh let's throw over a little bit
oh yeah oh i got it oh she just gave me
i just have your phone in my hand this
is so weird i feel like i
i feel like i literally have just like
oh my gosh oh it's an airplane mode
um so i'm okay okay so your most
recently used emojis
oh my god so funny the heart this you
this is really who you are
this honestly this is how you find out
who someone is on the inside look at
their recently used emojis
come on it's all hearts it's literally
all hearts and smiley faces with heart
mine is all the gun to the head the
skull the poison
the needle like look at it it's it's
it's the headphones smiley face with the
heart
turquoise dress what's that just when
i'm like talking about a designer i'll
be like dressed by
right this is a camera for giving photo
credit on instagram yeah oh yes okay so
some of these friends like giving credit
to people
that's awe that's nice it's not only
nice it's an excellent business move
you know that's how we elevate people
now the new economies we tag people
i see a lot of people they don't tag
anyone and i don't understand why people
do that it makes me so mad
or not nice celebrities will um
tag someone's stories but you don't
underline it so they can't click on it
and go there
i'm saying you boomer i've done it but
when they tag someone but don't yeah
make it clickable we don't need to call
it geriatric celebrities that seems mean
um music champagne
it's all happy chappie chicken i wish i
had a champagne oh my god look how happy
she is god damn it her emoji
okay so this to me tell this when i meet
someone a new guy i'm dating
just ask them first red flags can i just
see your most recent emojis
and you'll learn everything you need to
know about this person i'm telling you
good one
this is amazingly positive and healthy
girl yeah what are yours girl i can't i
can't with this
okay so i'm also dating someone younger
than me who loves emojis
um so mine hold on where's my
okay mine are wait also
you have 326 unread texts i have 271
okay we're both psychotics
um okay so mine are
um oh no the first one is this one
that's my main one my main one is the
face palm
yes my most frequently an eggplant
squirt
a panda what
wait that's true a fig leaf oh no the
panda is real
they're all real the panda the concert
ticket i don't know these feel like
they're
oh because you were talking about
tickets on the instagram
mermaid vibe the shell interesting a
hedgehog
sometimes i sometimes i send to um
people like my i have
two girlfriends who when i'm um feeling
like depleted and used and they're like
how are you i send a shell i'm like i
feel like a shell of a person
oh like i need to be fighting for
mermaids yeah like i need to be filled
up
you know what i'm saying um uh and
benjamin what are yours
mine are i do the single eyeball in the
mouth and the single eyeball to make
that little face like
i like that a lot i do the squirts too i
use it when i send my
friend pictures of makeup that i like
this card emoji with it
um i have a redhead that's from just
from where we're talking to santino um
i love this one with like the watery
eyes me too the cute one it's my
favorite one
right yeah that one's new and i love the
cowboy hat emoji
you shove an emoji i do i'm the little
blonde princess you do
but you know what i'm realizing about
you i just saw it happen this is
part of your um genius is your curiosity
that's it it's like because i i learned
that the person that's talking the most
knows the most but you're actually just
just the way you did that
you just were like what is that what is
that like i saw that's what it is that
is it
that's why can we go back to what you
said sorry i'm so into this the person
talking the most knows the most
no it's like it's like she's in a uh
observing
and asking quite the exact right
question that was like such the right
question to ask as a businesswoman like
you know what questions to ask
that was that i'm really impressed thank
you
like that's how you find out what's
popular is going what is that
why that curiosity that just blew my
mind i know you guys didn't see what i
just saw i know that this seems crazy
but that was
very few people do that you're making me
realize
more about myself very few people are
interested
she said very few people do that very
few people are interested in me so that
was crazy
no but just to do what is that and why
and
you know because you find because
because you're always ahead and now i'm
learning why
jim saying you're oh you're curious
about because i have this
uh new thing i have to learn i have a
dread about new things you have a
great let's learn it let's get ahead of
it i love learning new things it's like
you have an excitement about um new
tools and socials and stuff
[Music]
and i have a dread towards it really you
know
i'm like i have to learn another thing i
have to do you know what i mean
i love it i just i love experiences and
i love learning new things and
i don't know just experiencing new
things in life all the time
give me a bean give me a bean
and if what color
let's see this one
wait this is so weird do you know this
my favorite flavor is
prickly pear oh i picked it cause i
thought it'd be a booger and i wanted to
see burgers they're mostly just salty
but
prickly pear was the only jelly bean
flavor i would eat growing up i would
like throw fits in the mall
and my mom would have to drag me out
because i would only prickly pear jelly
beans
what is it it's burger
okay so um yeah so boogers like
it's a slice of slow burn it's salty
isn't it that's a slow burn and i was
like ready to have like a childhood
nostalgic like warm moment and
that just like took away my childhood
traumatized that just
that just undid all the therapy that
i've been doing for so long
um wait are you guys you're not in um
you're in therapy for you
no oh good you know what i literally
i was going to say so you're in therapy
absolutely not
honestly i was going to say like i don't
think you need to be in therapy i've
never
i've never said that to like anyone i
never say that to anyone but like
we've never told a guest that like
you're okay
like you're so good like i'm saying
like you're good you're salt like i have
no notes
like it's like this um um
i think you got to know when you're
doing well too i think we're in this
culture right now where it's all about
like
self-examining and that's great and um
and pointing out the things we need to
work on but you also got to know when
you're
failing at him when you're dope you know
what man
yep what i love the idea of you being
like you don't need anything and she's
just like
in paris it's just like i didn't ask
yeah um
nobody i didn't remember asking if i
needed help
oh my god i love you love that we
renovated the podcast studio
before my house which is so telling of
your priorities because i'm such a
workaholic
right my house is on hold but the
podcast studio and you
accidentally turned your entire upstairs
of your home into an office
but you didn't mean to was this an
accident at all this is my dream i now
get to just like work all day long
ours too yeah this is like an alcoholic
just like
popping in a bar so we renovated this
nook we should show it to you guys
you're never gonna see it you're not i
know it's off camera which is so stupid
though but i'm looking for
um a big like fan like a couch to put in
that's like simple and clean yep and
article furniture
you guys know i want this green couch
wait i'm just going to screen record it
show you guys
this don't you think this would be
perfect this green couch
grace that how cute that's perfect how
cute is it
can i tell you this is truly my actual
style of furniture i love it it's like
scandinavian
meets look modern meets warm
i don't like cold yeah yeah i like woods
such a good point i like rustic remember
my talk show i had i had wood in the
background resurrected wood everything
i like things to feel warm yeah like
kind of a cozy barn
right but i want it to be high quality
and that's what they do and i think i
guess
they first look at the price of that am
i allowed to say it out loud
that anywhere so reason that anywhere
else would be like seven thousand
dollars
like it's look at this super fair prices
fast affordable shipping and these
little side tables are
so good so i'm i'm obsessed with article
furniture
uh you save up to 30 over traditional
retail prices
they don't scam you like a lot of these
furniture stores
a lot of these furniture stores when you
go to them now they don't even have it
in stock anyway nope they do not they
don't have it nope
they'll go well now you have to wait
eight months to get your couch you're
like what article
we ordered it we got it like two days
later all my stuff all my um uh outdoor
furniture down by the pool is article
first i love it it's beautiful it's chic
it's like it's just it's a game changer
it's a game it's the me
of furniture i love that article is
offering our listeners 50
off your first purchase of 100 or more
go to article.com
whitney and the discount will be
automatically applied at checkout that's
article.com
whitney to get 50 off your first
purchase of 100
or more honestly
i am outraged about what today
your tone mostly never gonna change
um emily came in this morning i was like
okay she was it's just my face it's just
my face
enough feedback about it um i just think
it's unfair
that when you're at your most vulnerable
time in your life 17
18 you're 18 years old you've seen
movies
right about people go to college they
become they go to wall street they
become billionaires
right you go to college and your your
life is
fixed yep no no no no no no no no no
no it can be as it can be a rigmarole
as we say around here yeah you're
signing a contract you have no idea what
you're signing when you sign up for
student loans it's insane
you'll take over the rest of your life
because you i thought after i graduated
from college i would just get a check
for a million dollars
and a job at goldman sachs they uh and a
bentley they i went to college they
misled us
it is time to break out of the student
debt cycle ernest can help you by
refinancing your student loan
earnest offers low rate student loan
refinancing and you can check your rate
risk-free in just
two minutes because sometimes when you
check your rate oh then you get docked
then you get in trouble for checking it
i know
and you know what they don't teach you
that in college
[Laughter]
thank you university of richmond 200 000
education
it is time to stop feeling overwhelmed
by student debt i mean
you always are overwhelmed but that's my
face
ernest come through ernest is offering
our listeners a 100
cash bonus refinance your student debt
at earnest.com
whitney terms and conditions apply now
ernest is giving our listeners a one
hundred dollar
bonus refinance your student loans at
earnest.com
terms and condition supply once again
get you a hundred dollar cash bonus when
you visit earnest.com
whitney to refinance your student loans
not available in
all states terms and conditions apply
visit earnest.com whitney for more
details terms and conditions apply
earnest student loan refinancing made by
earnest operations
llc nmls pound sign one
two oh four nine one seven california
financing law license number six
oh five four seven eight eight three oh
three second street suite
401 n san francisco california
nine one visit earnest.com
licenses for a full list of licenses
penn should pay me for going to college
there
after i just read that without making
one mistake university of pennsylvania
you owe
me money now they taught her to read
what do you watch
june carter just sit and like watch
movies or are you guys always just like
let's build a business
we're mostly working but we started
watching shit's creek
just so funny so funny i love that show
but let me ask you a question you're
with someone who so i'm dating
my vet uh and he has to go we can't talk
about dogs anymore
because i'm like i have a million
questions you know the same way when
when people date me and they're like
tell me a joke and i'm like no i'm off
work right now do you guys have like
we're not working right now because
you're both work
mowgly type people or do you just go you
know what this is how both of our brains
work
let's just work all the time and find
the balance
we like i thought i worked hard like
this guy works harder than anyone i've
ever met in my life love it
which is so inspiring to me and
like obviously we take time off to be
romantic and cute and like enjoy life
but
most of the time we're always just
thinking of ideas and just working
together and just like
it's amazing to have like that like
power couple
vibe yeah i don't know it's different
it's so new to me because i'm not used
to being with someone who's
just so brilliant and hardworking he's
just like such an adult
he's just like a grown-ass man he really
is
you know i'm saying have you met his
family yes i love them
yeah um and uh do
should we know peop who people's ex
should we know people's exes
should we do we need to know do we i
don't need to know
no i don't even know what do you say
your definition of love is
feeling at home and safe great
love just yeah i think
being safe is the most important like
home
and trusting and being best friends and
i think something your
your documentary also made me realize is
sometimes you don't know what that feels
like
until way later in life you know like
you don't know
what's safe until you've been safe and
if you haven't ever been safe you have
nothing to compare anything to you know
so it's like
um you know watching the documentary was
just that was really powerful just go
like oh yeah
like like i thought i was in something
healthy but that's just compared to all
the super unhealthy things i was in
before you know what i'm saying it's
like
it was just such an interesting thing to
to watch um
that documentary just i know the major
takeaway was about you know the school
and then you passed this law
you know to get this abuse to stop and
it's it's it's brilliant i don't want to
make you
rehash it all here but um you know it's
like the person you choose
just is so um pivotal
to your business and your mental health
every day and like your documentary
really just helped like crystallize a
lot of that stuff for me
for me too yeah just showing like you
cannot take over the world if your man
is being insecure with you and making
about him or if your woman is like
causing texting you before the show
causing drama like you just
the person you're with is a business
decision you know and like i
feel like i saw it when i in that
documentary and like
i just got it i was like got it i'm
gonna stop chasing that guy that is not
interested in me that has given me
anxiety who's not texting me back before
a show and then the whole show i'm
thinking about him and then he's like
being weird and then wants me to you
know be in a selfie with him for his
feed
i you know i was like i'm done no yeah
this is this is fucking up my ability
to be a good business woman it's so true
it affects all
parts of your life it but i need your
documentary for some reason
like it was boom it just like clicked
for me like
that that was um a huge service because
i think so many
of us waste so much time in
relationships and fuck up our businesses
and our income and our potential
because we're just in a like a rat fuck
nasty toxic thing that we're stuck in i
know and then it never ends up working
out anyway so i was like what was the
point
and it just ages you that was at the end
of the day i remember therapists once i
was in this real life one of those kind
of relationships i was just like bad
like
you can't get out can't live with can't
live without said nancy type thing
and she goes you know that um uh being
stressed out releases cortisol
and uh that actually uh depletes
collagen right
and i was like are you telling me that
bad relationships make me look older
and she was like i could i was like okay
like that's
like i need to hear that got it he's out
um i'm gonna talk about your podcast
which i did the
uh the other day and fully embarrassed
myself i mean that couldn't have been
worse it could have gone worse no it was
so much fun couldn't have gone wrong
i couldn't have been more of an idiot i
just you know i had the faux
covered fog like what can i blame um but
uh yeah it was uh
it's it's so weird because i feel like
we've spent so much time in this
business trying to figure out what works
and it's like oh just us sitting around
talking
were we overthinking it this whole time
you know so tell me why did you start a
podcast i actually never even listened
to a podcast
until quarantine and then
i was listening to yours i just i loved
just how like fun and open and real you
were
and then um i got a call
that iheartradio wanted to do a deal and
it wasn't only just gonna be my podcast
i was gonna have my own
company so it's like a audio company
called london audio
where i could also use my platform to
share with others and create other shows
and produce them
and i think it's just fun yeah it's fun
just to be able to talk about whatever
you like and
i've been interviewed a billion times so
now it's like my turn to do that and i
like it
it's a major role you get to control the
narrative because i think it's like
that's so much of
the speculation you can't speculate
anymore on someone you can't project on
someone anymore you can't
like lie the way you used to be able to
lie because you're able to get your side
of the story out
right away clearly in a cogent way yeah
and also just
from years and years of doing interviews
and just always feeling on guard and
scared
like what are they going to ask me next
and just kind of always being nervous
and now not having to feel that way and
just being able to
speak what's on my mind and just be
myself it's a way
frame healthier way to communicate
you know what i mean like what we're it
is like the fact that we should like
go to a place and put and script a
conversation and go out and talk to a
stranger we've never met before who we
grew up
it's just like talk shit like all that
just it was crazy that we did all that
it was crazy what a like circus
rigmarole
so inauthentic so it just you know what
benton has uh
um and so in the podcast so what podcast
do you listen to now what do you like
about them
like what like because you're all you
always know something
gonna happen in 10 years what's
happening should we should we keep doing
this podcast
yes i think that audio is the future
and it's amazing just how many people
now
have their own podcast like i was just
listening to rashida jones and bill
gates podcast i think that's just like a
very cool
pairing yeah and i just did kate
hudson's one sibling reverendly with my
sister
and her brother oliver and that was just
so much fun just to like
have the siblings together talking about
just everything in life
because i feel like fans now they know
they know they're like no we know
they know the seven minutes on a talk
show or the 20 minutes is bullshit they
know it's
you know what i'm saying they're like we
just want to hear people talk like
there's a different expectation for
authenticity now
definitely you know and i'm glad that
audio is the future now that i'm aging
perfect time perfect time to be off
camera and all right it changes the
future and the past
we're like we hate radio we love radio
it's literally we're going back to
radio sitting by the radio and listening
to the radio or
like um prairie home companion or howard
stern or whatever like we've
you know we've always wanted to hang out
with somebody
um and just i've always wanted to hang
out with somebody
even with clubhouse just the new app
like yup
i love that it's a social media platform
it's not like a vanity platform it's not
about how you look or
posting a video or a photo it's just
about your voice and your knowledge and
people learning and just the community
on there is incredible i just see that
people are just so
generous with their time and just
speaking and helping others and i just
think it's a really
beautiful thing that's uh that's such an
amazing observation like
uh i love clubhouse and
it is they're generous with their time
and i'm learning that when i go on there
first i was like is this just chaos is
this toxic you know because some i get
overwhelmed
because i when you go into clubhouse if
you're verified or something everyone
knows you're in there
so then they'll call you up and then i
would like feel pressure but i figured
out a way to do like a secret profile so
i can just sort of like
spy and um i talk to a lot of people on
there who are like
you know it's just audio only it's like
a live chat room basically you know it's
a bunch of
just strangers you know talking about a
topic and a lot of people were saying
like
you know this is really helping me build
my confidence because i'm able to talk
in public but not you know it reminds me
of like old
like 2000s chat rooms where you could
like beat anyone yeah
be just talk to people yeah without the
pressure of like a picture
yeah yeah totally kind of scary totally
because i felt like the
that for it's so interesting that you're
like audio's the future because i was
like
like everything's visual now you know
instagram happened
take time everything's visual and then
it's so interesting how it like
vacillates
you know back and forth and back and
forth like audio visual but yeah it's
like ultimately
audio now like who would have thought
we're back to radio
we just want to hear people talk is your
mom going to be a guest
yes when is she joining the housewives
yes
are you thrilled um i haven't watched
the show in a while but there's so much
drama i'm hoping my mom doesn't
get into the drama but i think she's
gonna she'll be entertaining i think
she's gonna even everybody out
i'm obsessed with her yeah so she's
really dope
she's just like just an icon that's why
i'm like yeah the show needs that
they need someone to be like stop all
this
yeah i mean but i don't know if they
have control in the editing in the post
you know
she will i know she will figure it out
she will read it
like my daughters whatever this isn't
working
that's amazing yeah did you guys have to
talk about that
was it like uh she didn't want us to
know
she basically when we kept like reading
about it on tmz and just like
six i'm like mom that is so doing this
and she's like
no and then finally she like admitted to
it
and my sister and i talked about it like
if there was not a pandemic going on and
she wasn't
so bored there's no way she would have
agreed to do this
and she's never looked better too so i
think she wants to show off just how hot
she looks as well
as she should right she said you had a
show this is my turn
but she's probably already friends with
some of them i mean you know right well
your answer on there right
yeah you're but not but still yeah uh
yeah yeah you started the show uh but
i know but lisa is not you know my
housewife's knowledge is not excellent
is there anything you did that you miss
doing like acting singing are you gonna
do another album or anything i'm doing
music now
i love that i could just do whatever i
want so
like a lot of passions and i just do
them like the thing i do miss is djing
though i just love
is that going to come back and just like
100 000 people it's like amazing i think
it will come back soon not like now but
i
feel like by the end of the summer most
people have the vaccine
and then like herd immunity then it'll
be back and i feel like it's going to be
like
like the roaring twenties or everything
yeah yeah and go out i think it's great
that you do so many things i think so
many people are trained to think like i
have to pick one thing and do that
forever
i think it's really cool that you show
people like you can do all your
interests you can do them all
and it keeps people from being like in
such a box like i have to be the dancer
or i have to be
this stereotype or that one it's like
i'll just try all the things and
to go i'm gonna learn in public that's
what we're doing with podcasts
none of us like stand up act you get to
practice you go to schools you do
you learn private for so long and then
when you're good you go show it to
everyone now we're like
for you know i mean the first episode of
our podcast like it is dan levy from
shits creek was our first episode oh
that's
it yeah and it's like you know we'll
have to watch it at some point but when
you're like oh my god like we're just
learning in public you know it's just
like so funny the idea that we're like
starting a business probably santa's
kind of learning public but you've got
to search it out that's right but it's
not
a camera yeah you're going to go you've
got to go see someone but it's just so
interesting that we're working out the
kings publicly
you know yeah that's just the wild and
then um
okay benton uh uh we've talked about
this for benton did write a paper
in his high school yeah about paris it's
a big deal okay do
how was it received and what was your
grade do you want to tell us about this
psychology class
okay and we had to write a persuasive
paper
on something that we think everyone
should
believe in or like yeah and everyone
picked like political topics and
politics or like religions and i was
like i know
my religion and so i did i did a whole
extra thing i had like a i had like a
screen that
folded down and had all your movies i
brought them all in a wagon a red wagon
i had every one of them
and then it was like it was like
magazine covers and books and everything
it came down from the ceiling i said a
whole thing i was like flipped down
i had a laser pointer and i did a whole
full costume and then when i ripped it
was the costume
it was it was like a farmer for simple
life and then when i ripped it open it
had a shirt that i love paris hilton i
did a whole album review
i got an a yes crushing it
it makes me glad i want to see this did
you find it yet
my mom is like she's just scouring our
attic for it she's on her hands and
needs looking i don't know where she put
it
she kept it i know she keeps everything
so it's somewhere in that house that's
so cute i wish there was like a video of
you giving the presentation me too we
didn't have any of that back
there's no videoing god dear i know i
was watching that woody allen
documentary that i was like why do they
have so much
video of their childhood i guess they're
filmmakers whatever i was just like i
don't have
if i would you had a lot in your
documentary you guys filmed everything
yeah we had a lot was that your dad or
your mom my dad smart
well he probably he's he's you know he's
smart it seems like he's like shy and
he's like i'll do the
i'll hold i'll be behind the camera and
he's like the proud dad
just like filming his first daughter and
what does someone get you just love to
film things
my dad got a camera and it's all he
could do it's like stop it
no one wants to watch this blair witch
project rendition of me napping thank
you
so much that was me just sleeping in
pizzas
um okay so if we're gonna be friends i
have a couple questions for you i don't
know
if we're gonna be friends i don't like i
feel like what does someone bought what
is a gift
what is what do you what does someone
get you as a present
if i can't get someone a present i can't
be friends with them because i love
buying people presents i like
anything with unicorns oh well that's
mine you can't have it
okay i like it oh i love rainbow bright
yeah i know it's in the fashion
what toy is the best right i was the
growing up where i was like every um uh
little cartoon i had to have a horse i
loved all the ones with horses
i love you you're a horse girl right you
i love all animals i love horses
well that was really my first like i was
like this
she's got 50 dogs and they're all in her
purse i feel like we're going to be
friends
i feel like we're both hoarders items
what's your most prized possession oh
like what's the thing that you're like
this is the thing i'm grabbing well i
was at your house and i it
if you've been to her house that's a
really wild question because it is
her house is um it's it's um
it's a museum of prized possessions yeah
you know but yeah what would it be
that's a good question
my 21st birthday is my skin yeah
my 21st birthday dress like sparkly
iconic dress i love it all right
i remember it silver like
like julian mcdonald dress that was like
all made out of the swarovski crystals
sick you should have your own you know
like britney spears has the zone
where they have or you need one of those
yeah a timeline building
it looked i remember it did look a
little painful was it line on the inside
see what i
when i did the roast it was no it wasn't
when i did the roasted donald trump i
wore the
sequin dress and i took it off and i was
covered in scratches
like i was bleeding and i remember
seeing this and going is she okay what
if that scratches her
it looks so good i didn't care
do you feel like you get the credit you
deserve for social media
i think now you have to i think now
people feel sure they know
that i'm the og yeah yeah it's now it's
like it's
very it's very clear because i think
like like f when instagram started there
was like a murky
wild to think about though there's so
many people that just couldn't have a
career
otherwise it's how do you do that i
would just
i would just throw in all day and be
like everyone is so lucky
um but that you were the guinea pig
but there's also these people like you
you remind me of these icons these like
that that are that are so um smart
about the way they're what they share
like i was reading about betty page you
know betty
not betty paige um hedy lamarr hedy
lamarr was a famous movie star in the
30s
she lives in florida and no one saw her
after she was like
60 or something she just doesn't let
anyone photograph it did you watch her
film
yeah the documentary yes that's why i
picked that director because
alexander dean directed that film
amazing and i
didn't even know who hedy lamarr was and
i was just blown away by her story and
just how misunderstood she was you
remind me of her
thank you she was this gorgeous movie
star
that that did this um sort of like
risque scene and got all this like
negative attention
and then she was an inventor she was a
businesswoman she like and
you know she was like designing model
airplanes but she was so gorgeous nobody
really took her seriously and she was
kind of like be
like i've always thought of you as like
a hedy lamarr
thank you yeah what was it like when you
invented the airplane
but i just mean like and and i almost
think that like
you in a way there's an advantage
like i think there's been a disadvantage
but now there's like
i don't know i just feel like you've
adapted so well this you're like okay
think what you want
i'm gonna be uh over here doing my like
you've managed to make everything
um uh benefit you and serve you
like is that a muscle where you're like
you know what i'm just this is gonna
serve me this is gonna fucking serve me
i think so just like back in the day
when people would like underestimate me
i felt sometimes i would learn a lot
more about people
because they didn't realize that i
understood what was happening
so it was easier to read people because
they
thought it was just going over my head
but really i was watching everything
you're creepy man that's she's a little
sneak in the corner just like
you're underestimating me i'm just
that's what i feel like you're like
studying
people you know it's like do it's like
do not conflate my
aquarium my my kindness with weakness do
not conflate my silence you know so it's
like
silence people on women they project
what they're going to project their sex
of shit and it's just like so
interesting to me what everyone
projected on you and now to know that
you were just like plotting and
calculating and
it's just like it's so funny to me that
like that whole time you're just like
i'm just building an empire y'all can
project whatever the fuck you want and
i'm just catching my checks like i just
that's so
dope instead of like focusing on the
negative you know
like that's all we can do life's too
short
have fun so gross how short life is i
know
you know um i love you
we only have 10 minutes left with you i
will say for life to be so short
the impression you made in such a short
amount of time
yeah is just wild i mean
wild and can i tell you something i
actually do
because you know i i saw i mean i lived
on we were neighbors in
what 2005 or something six we did not
know each other
you lived in her guest house
i squatted in your gut's house for you i
have something to tell you
um and uh i remember i'd see
these car like it was physically
dangerous like you were in physical
danger all the time i just remember
being like
i couldn't get to my house because of
all the cars like this was a time where
it was um
physically dangerous to be famous i
remember going oh this is going to be
like a princess diana situation
you know that's how paparazzi were out
of control it was wild
that street like yeah it was insane yeah
like
50 cars it felt like like a red carpet
every time i left my house or just be
like
all of them like lined up from the
moment i would leave my house
follow me all day and night it was crazy
but it's like you seem to have this and
i think we all need to figure out like
what our um
compasses in terms of adversity when
you're going like
this sucks but it's gonna benefit me in
the long run it seems like you really
know
when you're like okay this sucks it's
gonna benefit me in the long run
you know what i'm saying and knowing
when adversity is gonna be positive or
negative just like
yeah but the truth is like there are
tons of we can go and say like
there are many many um
children of celebrities or people in the
know
that could not have done what you did
and that's the thing it's like we can we
can paint this picture of like oh well
she was
born in air it doesn't matter because
there was only one of you and everything
you did was
very specific it was very like it could
it's not something that's replicated if
it was
there'd be a 50-60 of you yeah but
there's not
yeah it's wild and that's just like
really wild to think about
one person just doesn't want to say i
look like a um
uh like a someone who was i look like
someone who was molested on the
scientology ship
me i don't need that when you call me on
the phone yes you have a big
fan hi we were just talking about you
um you guys having a little podcast yes
i just said what are you watching and
she started talking about your show and
i said stop
talking about he doesn't need any more
awards or viewers
we're cutting that we're cutting that
part of the segment well thank you for
watching the show
i'm obsessed it's the best thing on tv
like
congrats you killed it thank you so much
we're cutting that
no you're not cutting it
cutting it cutting it we're good oh my
god
um i loved your documentary it was
really really necessary
um and i hope you guys were talking
about it and talking about some fun
wonderful things
thank you i appreciate whitney get out
of the shot
[Laughter]
i feel like look what is this outfit i
panicked when
it's a weird it's like a bad sailor moon
situation
i'm so sorry i think i got it from david
rose's closet
you should be there no i don't know i
would say i think
paris is closer to david rose's closet
than you are
okay you've got a black and white
situation that's looking
really beautiful on camera i don't know
what that unicorn
nonsense is what did i do we have to
reshoot this whole interview i've been
wearing this whole time
what is this i look insane i look like a
sad boy in the 20s
i've just stuck a fork in a socket so
that's how you're catching me
um well enjoy the rest of your chat
it was very nice thank you for watching
and um keep it up please thank you babe
i can't talk right now gotta i gotta go
stop calling me i gotta go stop calling
me
god i fucking love him iconic
yeah so good and i think that you know
and something that's sweet to hear him
so he liked my movie
so you're also making me realize that
it's like my
i've look i made my car making fun of
people making jokes being
like you're making me realize like and
dan is one of those two he dan levy from
shit street
kindness can be funny yeah you can have
a good heart and be funny i grew up
learning like you have to be mean you
have to be nasty
comedy has to be negative that still is
funny but like there
is you know i'm learning like
heartwarming
i think we're going to next what time it
plays like the roast we're all agreeing
yes that we can be mean there that was
like a roasts were
you're showing up and everyone knows the
rules we're all eviscerating each other
and nothing's personal
we always took it personal i cried for
two hours after every roast you know
but um but you agreed to it yes so we've
all agreed
yes yes so but like at a comedy club if
you're buying a ticket and you come to
enjoy someone yeah being mean to you is
very strange totally it's a we
it's a weird thing now i'm finding
myself like in this new world of like oh
yeah that's kind of like
i just hurt someone you know like it's
it's it's finding that line as a
comedian moving forward humane comedy
like humane funny but not um
careful yeah funny funny but not careful
that's exactly the way to put it
because careful comedy is just not funny
but um
uh it's just an inch it's interesting to
see the evolution and it's like you've
been
at a weird crux of of illuminating this
yeah in a big way
definitely i mean it's kind of wild like
it's just kind of wild that you've been
like a part of this like history of
comedy in a weird way and like what this
pivot is about to look like
it's kind of insane and it's sort of
like held a mirror up to all of our
internalized
you know misogynist you know whatever
it's like
you've helped us evolve as a species you
know and like look at ourselves
it's good i think i'm happy for the
people who you know
i had to go through a lot and be like
treated cruelly and like
it was really hard but i'm happy that
things are changing now so that other
young girls don't have to go through
that same thing because it hurts when
you know people are being mean and
making jokes on your expense
and it's always that everyone's got on a
different scale whether it's that one
bully at school in front of two people
or if you're the most famous person in
the world and you're
you know it's like it's like it's you
have to be in on the joke
yeah interesting i mean it's just like i
mean anything i mean like
like the simple life do you think that
would happen today
i think people would try to copy it but
it wouldn't be
what it was it's just like a
one-of-a-kind thing
it was like a moment in time yeah it was
such a moment in time
do you did you ever do a scripted show i
remember when we were doing um
i was doing some shows and there was
like it was everyone would say like look
at paris look
like everyone just wanted to get you on
their show for like sweet i did like
cameos
that's right you would like pop in on
there yeah yeah do you have good
girlfriends
not very very good but some people i
trust it's just hard
i've just had so many girls just use me
and talk behind my back or just
do things that are just not what a
friend would do
so and when you have when you're so
tight with a sister it's really hard you
know what i mean you'll just
go to her yeah right and nikki's very
protective of me and
she's like a good read of people yeah
yeah
it's tricky because i um uh like
are you sharing friends with carter do
you have friends like
do you guys have similar friends right
we just hang out with each other we're
just best friends and we're always
together and
we hang out with his family a lot and my
family mm-hmm
but i don't know especially since
quarantine there's not
uh we just stay at home yeah are you
able to have platonic guy friends well
yeah
because i'm engaged no i just mean like
in general like
once you get engaged like i'm always
interested in like you know once we
how you know which guys have to go
you know yeah there's definitely a lot
of people i just wouldn't hang out with
because i think it's disrespectful yeah
see that's what i need to get into where
it's just like
there's certain obstacles and respect
things yeah
podcast news music coming
yes when i just released a music video
on valentine's day called heartbeat
yes which carter is in which
she's the type that would never be
anything like that but i was like please
literally watching this
i'm sorry carter is so hot he's such a
like businessman
i would have such a hard time so her her
um my dude is like a
vet too with like a real job and he'll
come home and he'll be doing something
like
doing your big business like it's just
like he's
like your dude is such a business man i
know i love it
it's so it's so hot um okay what else
what were we talking about what else is
going to um
uh uh coming out you what you don't need
us to promote you i don't know
what am i doing you guys can follow her
on parishhilton.com
uh yeah i just launched my new website
calm and my new podcast this is paris
the iheart you're having fun i love it
so good
and um my 29th fragrance just came out
29th fragrance what's it called pink
rush
good smells beautiful
and a new makeup line is coming out and
then i have 19 product lines so
all those new lines are always coming
out and
yeah writing my book right now yes
wait you know benton just told me
sometimes uh makeup on amazon is fake
makeup on amazon makeup like if you
order makeup online
it might be fake well yeah like you know
like like counterfeit
yeah counterfeit like they'll be like
because you know some things are just
exclusive to other places
okay some people may have bought it and
replaced it or some people may be like
selling
their like version of it well
people come in all the time and when i
worked at mac and they would
return but i i need to return this and
we'd be like this isn't real
and like counterfeit like max right but
this is just a sticker from a different
product
of this and then it was just they're
really like that's crazy
i did it with dip tea candles remember i
ordered all those dip tea candles and
they weren't dipped in they were just
somebody used them and just melted her
the case yeah like there's a lot you
know so it's just
the makeup world is so fast we had a
lady come back and uh return a jar of
moisturizer but she refilled it little
mayonnaise of lemaire
she took my she's it was mac moisturizer
and my manager went this is mayonnaise
oh my god
oh then what do you do to your skin and
then we're gonna let you go i have my
skincare line called paris hilton pro
dna
why don't i have that why not i'm gonna
give it to you get it in my body okay
and i stay out of the sun
and i get facials and well that's how i
stay
and you make you um reduce stress in
your life and you have someone that
yeah for sure like that makes a huge
difference
it's so interesting when you see someone
that's in love with someone that doesn't
make their life hard and they look
better than they've ever looked likely
you look so rested and healthy
like you look like you're in a
relationship with a guy that doesn't
do dumb i know like the royal family gee
what throwing grenades
but like um uh you know what i mean like
you're in something healthy
and it's obvious thank you glowing
yes sir i love you you're glowing too
i'm not i'm just hot and sweaty because
i wore this weird sweatshirt for you
and now i'm so hot i don't even know
what i'm doing
um i love you so much we're gonna make
you come back a billion times
um or uh we'll be um paris hilton's
on your pot do you own this podcast are
you our boss
i'm just curious is this your podcast is
there you here to tell
is that why you came today yes um
and uh and also you did not need to come
today there's
you don't need this you're totally you
walk the walk and you
show up for people and you like you know
i don't think we're
you know you're not this isn't gonna get
great
like you know pay you money like you're
doing this out of the kindness of your
heart and i appreciate that
and that's awesome would you like a
jelly bean on your way out okay one last
jelly bean
we'll end on a jelly bean kill myself
okay
one last jelly bean no don't log you
can't look okay
okay you on your
one last jelly bean do a white one
like this yeah pure white with no
speckles
oh my god i don't know why i have such a
bad reaction to these oh my mine was
actually good
marshmallow yeah no i got coconut
what was your spoiled milk such a bummer
and such a bummer oh my god wow you're
so lucky
at least i got my taste back post
covered cause i know my taste back
i love you guys um don't ride elephants
um i love you i love you i love you i am
these very awkwardly
loves it i guess
[Applause]